neue außerhalb kalender ist da und
schaut mal wie hübsch geworden ist den
könnt ihr euch jetzt völlig kostenlos
runterladen dasteht wir so ziemlich
jedes gemüse drehen weil man das im haus
vorzieht weil man das nach draußen
pflanzt man das nach draußen aussehen
kann da haben wir hier oben diese
symbole einmal im haus vorziehen dann
direkt ins b zellen und nach draußen aus
pflanzen und jedes gemüse ist da auch
immer mit nummern versehen weil wir
meinen kanal schon länger verfolgt der
weiß ja dass ich ganz gerne gemüse
gestaffelt aussehen also die möhren zb
fast jeden monat neue nach sehe damit
man dann auch rund ums jahr ernten kann
und damit ihr da nicht durcheinander
kommt sind die gemüse setzte so nennt
man das immer auch mit einer nummer
markiert also schaut gerne mal rein das
ist wie gesagt völlig kostenlos ich
verdanke ich den kalender hier oben und
nochmal unten in der video beschreibung
ihr könnt euch den als pdf herunterladen
zum beispiel aufs handy oder auch
ausdrucken so wie ich und da auch rein
schreiben wir haben dieses mal auch
extra größere kästchen gemacht ist man
die schrift besser lesen kann hier ist
noch ein platz für notizen
ich habe auch noch einen kleinen
erklärungstext dazu geschrieben also
viel spaß mit dem kalender ich hoffe er
gefällt euch das ist einfach mein
geschenk für euch wie das neue
gartenjahr mit wieder alle zusammen
richtig schön durchstarten können und
dann sehen wir uns vielleicht nächste
woche ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz
sicher weil ich eine super viel um die
ohren habe und auch sehr gerne mal
wandern gehen möchte also es kann sein
dass er im dezember nicht ganz so viele
videos online kommen wieder
normalerweise aber im januar bin ich
dann wieder voll für euch da das steht
noch nicht so ganz fest ein zwei videos
kommen auf jeden fall und der rest
schauen immer also noch eine schöne
woche hier raus und macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und vielleicht sehen wir
uns dann am nächsten samstag wieder